who rocket
ship round two with Nicole
Ortega welcome back to the show you
giggly bundle of cells
thank you thank you for having
me you're
welcome well we're going to see if
Nicole's gonna even be able to utter
cohesive words this stream or if it's
just gonna be Blissful
Giggles that's the whole
show he's like oh you got it right
through telepathy that's
right yeah the reflection is blissful
Giggles for New Earth
basically this whole this whole video is
just going to be one Blissful reflection
for New
Earth it's
ridiculous oh my
gosh I love
it
oh
okay see the the thing is because we
have our basic needs met we can giggle
uncontrollably that's
it no fear no fear baby
yeah exactly no scarcity no
fear
gosh it's so much harder to just Bliss
out when like the body's just fearfully
scarcely needing to move to get a basic
need
so this is like the the God's God's
highest will is basic needs on Earth
because it enables this Blissful Giggle
and freedom
creativity
BL yeah or the knowing that there's
always
replenishment cuz I feel like there
could be people experiencing the basic
needs yet
still will run
out
so right right replenishment basically
Infinity yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
nice yeah yeah yeah so it's it's
interest so it's infinite basic needs
yeah
EXC yeah yeah infinite basic needs
yeah nice I love
that I actually sometimes when people
pay me for programs I'm like send me
8,888 it's always
infinite
oh yeah the infinity eights are infinity
signs I just got
that
yeah right
right
I guess this is the mode that is
uh there's there's like this mode which
is just a total
cheese and then there's
like just bringing new Earth
as Catalyst because there's so much so
much contraction in the planetary
roots and like
giggling can
only it's a it's a different form of
catalyst in a way to
cease like Jo like joy and like eminent
Joy is its own Catalyst of
like peace and decentralization and that
kind of stuff
um I know you you you wanted to do a
show and talk
about something you were offering I
think but we've been we've been cheesing
for like two hours before this catching
up and then uh talking about all kinds
of [__] and
then and the beginning of this rocket
ship was just Bliss and I guess we
titled the episode about Prosper poverty
to Prosperity so basic infinite basic
needs is going to come up but what was
the program or whatnot that you wanted
to bring
up what was it let's see I forgot I'm
like this is so fun um
bringing people into this Prosperity
Consciousness so I'm helping people
shift from La mindset into Infinite
abundance and it's not numbers because
I've had lots of millionaire
clients that live in lack and poverty
Consciousness so it's it's not a number
it's a
frequency
yeah and when people taste feel
experience that gumminess of I'm always
going to be supported I'm always going
to be provided I can relax right Rel
that's
priceless nice okay so do you want to
offer that as a
reflection is like a
constitutionalization as infinite basic
needs or abundance to
just and any limitation that's
preventing that to be obliterated
basically right cuz I mean the level of
joy that I
have
experienced that I have received by the
experience of my clients and students
receiving joy out
of bursting the bubble of the rat
race like the joy that they can find in
their families in their marriages in
their health in their well-being in
their passions and
like eradicating the problem of poverty
changes every single aspect of
somebody's
life
mhm now now you said that um for people
that already have a lot of money that it
can sometimes be that there's not a a a
feeling of of
abundance but there's still scarcity or
fear and that kind of stuff but what
about the
opposite oh that's yeah so like this
what about this reflection for someone
that doesn't have any money and that
they're how how uh to break a limits
that are like the
bodies I mean like the most poverty like
the most poverty imaginable like like a
total slum and yeah yeah that's why I've
been in this journey for two years I I
play this slum so I chose to be homeless
and like travel with no money to test if
I could if the universe actually was
going to support me
so
it did I mean I always received what I
needed the moment I need it and a bit
more it's like magic it's like it always
Consciousness supports
itself so if somebody that has nothing
lives on the streets shifts the belief
that they can be supported no matter
what they instantly would get a
reflection of an opportunity that will
open up a portal for them to have a
different frame of reality of more
abundance and the loop keeps increasing
so it works for
[Music]
anybody
so so this like yeah this distributed
network of of Consciousness is always
supporting itself kind of as long as
it's open to
receiving and it's bringing forth go
ahead that's what it is it's an openness
you
receive
right yet deeper than that like to me it
was cellular memory of poverty
conditioning like it's not as simple as
well to me it wasn't as simple as
telling myself you'll always be
supported I had to
Feel It In My Bones kind of thing like
it was a recalibration of
DNA yeah yeah nice yeah sematic
right interesting so the the poverty
conditioning is very or scarcity
conditioning is very somatic and
cellular and that's where a good amount
of The Liberation happens
in in like body in body scanning
yes body scanning
and just being aware of the
sensations that's how perhaps my whole
passion for self-realization tied with
uncovering the unreality of poverty
Consciousness because we need the state
of awareness to hold the space for those
contractions to dissolve into the
infinity Pole
of and abundance yeah interesting
yeah yeah it just came up like I don't
know some some days ago like or a week
ago or something just like driving and
then there was like that I didn't know
what to do because of the toll road
thing I didn't know exactly if I had the
thing that I needed or not cuz it was a
new car and all this kind of stuff and
just you could feel the traction of like
avoiding the toll just in case of like
not having what you need and that kind
of stuff and you can like you can
definitely sense sense sense it it's
like a sens it's definitely a sensation
it's definitely a contractive sensation
when uh when something that's infinite
doesn't take the
infinite
abundant route route yeah jinx
jinx
yeah it's so bodily like every new
choice that I took in the steing quest
that was just me looping myself in
Infinity my own psyche it was like I had
to push myself and my body to take the
next highest abundant investment action
right as little as like now I'm going to
pay more for my rent or now I'm going to
take the first class flight or now I'm
going to empty my bank account to
support a friend and trust that I'm
going to be resupport it like every
single action like my body was like but
I did it like shaking because I knew it
was going to recalibrate right right
yeah yeah yeah nice that happened
recently too maybe like a month or two
ago like supporting a friend even though
I was getting very close to zero uh so
but that it was like a shake one and it
was a beautiful recalibration
yeah it's like
you did you say it's like magic yeah go
on tell
me just yeah it is a it's a beautiful
recalibration or like you
know it's like you're living what I just
made a content on which was about like
the human network is is a reflection of
the of the decentralized distributed
biology system
so if the trees and the mushrooms
underground are exchanging resources in
harmony without senses of selfs and
centers and contractions and all kinds
of things like that then you can feel it
in your own body when you let go of you
like live the
actual uh the the actual constitution of
being a distributed Network without a
center you like you live it you know yes
and that's how Consciousness can support
itself because it's receiving on the end
where the money is being sent and
supported and then it's uh and then it's
being replenished where uh and more by
taking these incremental
expansions like yes that's exact I mean
what a beautiful visual nice because
it's such a delicious permission slip to
do that and see how to center these
Souls out of the
self-transcendent experience
of releasing control
mhh it's full
surrender yeah that's what that's it
that's a good way to that's a good way
to describe it that's a perfect um
releasing of control and surrendering by
um Believe by by believing destroying
the limit and believing in abundance and
and um and infinite basic needs
basically
yeah yeah yeah like the mushrooms and
trees and whatnot there's no concept of
limitation nature it's gross and gives
yeah and receives it's it's the infinite
giving and receiving loot
yeah yeah exactly everything in the soil
networks is just constantly and giving
and receiving yeah it's just
it's it's literally scientists have been
trying to track and it's just so
difficult to try to track and understand
what's going on in soil it's so
difficult because it's so um osmo it's
like it's like interpenetrative osmosis
on steroids it's crazy yeah the [__] the
stupid interdependence interpenetrative
steroids interpenetrative osmosis on
steroid
steroids
okay the weirdest way to describe a
biological
Network
yeah that's what humans are are like too
but then there's all of the contractions
and it's it does start within it starts
with one's own cellular memory 100% 100%
because that that repattern everything
um
even just the
like um poverty Consciousness is pretty
strong with
um no not only being open to receive but
also learning how to
ask yes yeah and like being the
basically there's a whole retraining
process with the fearlessness that's
associated with and confidence that's
associated with
asking right it's humble
yeah it's it's
the the energy behind the asking though
because when that's
reprogrammed like I ask every day every
day I'm just like but with like
excitement and joy yet in poverty
Consciousness the ass comes from beggar
Consciousness and with shame and guilt
and apathy and pride so that that's what
blocks the Synergy of the inter
penetration of Life
yeah a
creation
yeah okay and then uh when it doesn't
when it doesn't come from the ask where
where what word did you use for the ask
if it's coming from shame what what what
beggar Consciousness what yeah what's
what's non-bar asking
called equal co-player of The Game of
Life okay cool yeah yeah like a equal
co-player basically
yeah yeah
great super resonant because that's kind
of
where the ask is coming from a place of
like basically the network in a way the
ask is coming from a network instead of
from l it's kind of like when the
mushrooms this is what I'm saying this
shit's really fascinating how scien ISS
trying to understand this but it's
basically sending some sort of like an
electrical chemical signal pheromonal
biological signal across all of those
domains of sense and electricity and
whatnot and then and then that's the
request for what it
needs yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
there's no beggar yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah shame or whatever
yeah it actually sends a
signal yeah yeah right you don't have to
take an action I mean it just happens
through you happens through you exactly
yeah yeah it happens through you like
it's just the signal itself knows how to
navigate the web yeah because when when
we're out of the way when we're not
Contracting yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's lots of ancestral things
with this um that are the pro the
program patterns in the cells all kinds
of things with this I mean especially
lineages that have had um their entire
stacks of of
uh of of homes or um or businesses or
whatever due to war or
um
um genocides or all kinds of things that
they've had to be abandoned
um yeah all kind all kinds of [__] like
that and then
um and then just re basically the energy
Mastery that's associated with the
reprogramming of opening the channel to
abundance after all of that
contractin the
contractin
[Music]
contrac which is beautiful
yeah yeah it's so cool though that this
like Infinity contracts like that it's
actually the coolest thing imaginable is
that it's doing
that it's almost it's almost so cool
that you want to keep holding
on but then you but then you realize
that that that you came to learn how to
[Laughter]
stop how to go though like I mean yeah
Paradox instead of stopping how to stop
Contracting yeah and therefore how to go
in expansion yeah
yeah it's
like just the
flow I'm I'm very excited that the start
to this episode we've been going 22
minutes but I'm so excited that it went
into the biomimicry of biology like
because I'm such a [__] nerd about
that and and just like putting that in
all of our da infrastructure for basic
needs abundance on Earth and and I like
how you're bringing it into the level of
the the body and the cellular level of
the body the somatic level and the
reprogramming on the sensorial level I
love that love that inter I love that
and I love how we started talking about
like I love how you have all that uh the
the Flora in the background too I think
that's a perfect yeah
[Music]
exactly um and I love how we uh we
started talking about like what is it
like when the channel is opening up like
what is it like doing this deep
programming or
delimiting and then what is it
um what are these expansions like and
then what is the flow like what are our
like sign posts that were on the
right on the right flow so why don't you
hit that tennis ball for a
bit how do we know that we're in the
flow what are some of the core
releases and then what are and then what
are some of the core signals that the
flow is
unobstructed oh that's a really cool
question
nice the inability to feel
fear okay so that's that's a that's a
pretty strong first one okay yeah yeah
nice I'm going like there's no fear ah
okay baby steps maybe well that no
that's good we can let's let's just
start with that like the inability
starting the
end okay okay so interesting so you you
would say that that's like the most F
foundational is like the yeah the
inability to fear feel fear slash
scarcity slash contraction
around the abundance and infinite basic
needs and being held by the
universe supported by the universe as
the
universe yeah like I can't feel fear
like
impossible yet I had to test it like I
can give you like a concrete example
times like where I had absolute nothing
and I would sit on a coffee shop with my
two suitcases because I'm like okay I'm
going to travel with no money but I want
all my clothes right
anyways people sat in front of me like
out of
nowhere and offer me stuff and talk to
me and we're kind like and every time I
I opened up a new level of fear like a
friend calls me out of nowhere like okay
I spent my last $2,000 let's say a
friend's like hey right now I'm just
happen to fly exactly where you're going
to be at and I have a new Airbnb you
want to stay with me things like that I
mean you showed up in Paris
like things like that it's impossible
like you sent a signal I didn't have to
like text anybody I don't have to like
ask for help I just sit down I mean my
body was like [__] but I knew it wasn't
my mission or whatever I was doing what
I came here to do and then
things just show up
so I feel like that's how I can transmit
that fearlessness to people because I
think like if you haven't placed
yourself in enough life for that
situations it's really hard to like
fully trust
it
yeah okay
so one of the uh pathways to
recalibration at a cellular level is to
place oneself in scenarios more and more
often where you can kind of experience
the
contractivity and an expanse of
receptivity and a trust and allowance
that you'll get the right
the right calls or the right um support
um and then that that brings the fear
more and more out
of well I think I was edgy I'm not
suggesting people to do what I did I'm
just I just went all in I'm like I don't
care about my life like I was willing to
die like I was like I rather die than
live in that mindset right
so yeah I'm not suggesting people to do
that I'm just saying that's how I could
break how intense that lineary was in my
system well that's usually what happens
on the path
to uh realization is
that uh there's a burning passion for
truth it's like I'm either going to die
or I'm going to figure figure out what I
actually am um and yeah and so I guess
is similar in the sense of destroying
the Fe fear city cellularly is I'm I
would rather face the most uh
crazy
scenarios
uh and be go beyond scarcity and fear
Consciousness then even live that for
another
second I guess I guess it's equivalent
to separation in a way in that
sense cuz one's
transcending separation and transcending
self as they go into the on the journey
and I guess it's similar where you're
transcending separation and transcending
fear and
transcending uh
scarcity so it's a crucial part of
realization it seems like is to be
supported by literally the the the
energy field of the universe or whatever
you want to say which is has
no how could this what makes everything
how could it have lasted
exactly yeah the impossibility to
believe in lack and how that opens up
the channels of creativity like the
genius not only supported by the
universe in the way of people but I was
just getting messages of what to put out
there and instantly people were so
excited to receive it in a form of
business in a form of trade in a form of
creativity and davor people it's like
what am I going to do if I quit my job I
need to figure it out first what's my
entrepreneurship now before I quit no
quit the job be like okay I have two
days to pay my rent exactly boom you're
going to get the yeah yeah yeah nice
yeah I I do that too I see I see more
where you're coming from there that's
nice
right right because if if we're not
putting out into if if we're not
allowing the universal flow to go
through the body to put out the
that like we were saying this
electrochemical mysterious mushroom
signal then then then it's not going to
come you got to put out the fairmon
basically as whatever the offerings are
um cuz basically service is another
way um to say like whatever your unique
gift is your unique gift can be met in
whatever way that's another thing
probably some of the people that were
calling you to support you had had
experiences with you where they felt
like you were serving them or nourishing
their Journey if of course yes okay
right it's always an equal energy
exchange because what they did with me
was exactly what what I did with them
was what they had to do with me like
they were happy that I had raisen myself
to that level so they could experience
that exchange it all happens in a higher
self-communication level right right
right
right okay so okay so what what happens
what is their report when they tell you
that there's something that was
communicated at the level of the higher
selves with um with basically a ripeness
to to provide when it was needed
like what was that it was just the flow
the universe that or was there a
describing of what it was from their end
or not really like it wasn't really
discuss it was like an inner knowing
inot
ends and meaning it was like a word it
was a
wordless
um meaning wordless in the sense that
you didn't even ask with word you kind
of radiated out let's say and there was
like a an obvious
real seeing of like whatever value was
being provided or whatnot and then kind
of yeah
okay so interesting because at this
point it's
just it goes beyond human and it's just
like the level of energy behind
intentionality like how everything just
flows out of intention and
right an
action right yet we need the space to
receive because only those and vice
versa when people have appeared in my
field for me to support with my gifts
and my service they are radiating that
frequency and sometimes I pick it up and
they don't even reach out and I reach
out and I give them something they need
in that moment can you slow down a
little bit what did you just
say okay someone I love yeah go ahead go
ahead yeah okay okay what were you
saying I love
what I love how it goes to the level of
subtlety of energy because
sometimes I receive the signal of the
beings that need my support and they
don't even need to reach out to
me okay and I just it's an inspiration
and I give them exactly what they need
in a moment they need it and then it
balances itself out but so then what do
you do do you call them when is that
normally what's happening I I get
inspired to send a DM to someone or an
email or it's just like oh this person
needs to receive this and then right
right okay they're like oh my God I was
just asking for this it's like it just
happens in a telepathic level to to me
that's like my consistent experience
right
basically it's kind of like the whatever
the universe is kind of doing the the
stuff and it's like who whoa like yeah
yeah it's like I I'm not driving my body
it's just like okay whatever has to
happen yeah exactly yeah yeah
yeah
right
so that's
great yeah that's great because that's
more and more of
what getting completely out of the way
is
it's just doing doing itself full full
surrender is that what you're
saying yeah yeah and TR and trust and
faith that everything's already taken
care of in that in that flow and that
there's almost like
um like the intelligence that moves the
body to do that telepathic connecting
thing is like way more
intelligent than
whatever idea like
uh like I don't even know what to
describe the small so I don't know how
to describe it it's just like that's
cool you're like you're like I can't
even remember how to describe
it what is that thing what is the Contra
what is that
[Music]
person yet it's equally like mundane too
it's like when I say oh what's the
person it's like okay yeah it's the most
ordinary human thing it's like me
without the phobia or Neurosis me with
without like the it's just like relax
right right nice that's a good way to
put it you know without phobia and
Neurosis just relaxed flow
fullness
yeah yeah nice spot on
yeah
nice nice the relaxed flow fullness
definitely takes
the the experience to all kinds
of uh ways that when it's not that can't
or however you would say
it like the the relaxed flow takes the
body to all kinds of cool
new expansive
abundant yeah
versus I don't know what
to yeah versus like What's happen it's
just like oh now this is my house oh
you're my new friends oh now this is
here oh this is my new creative business
that I just typed or something typed it
through me I mean it's so easy it's so
much I mean that's to me that's actually
truly living before that you're not
living you're just like trapped right
right nice like liess fion excitement
wonder and like every day I'm just like
oh it's gonna happen today it's like the
best TV show
right so fun
nice yeah I love that yeah yeah at the
actual
living yeah that's really the key that's
really the key thing yeah it's like
um yeah like like the universal flow
puppeting the body towards the the
Divine aim
of the cosmos and the Divine name of
this Earth
and and it's more like really living CU
there's no doing that's what's the nice
thing sometimes it's kind of funny
because like sometimes like um
like there's like a big there's like
this big thing that like takes so many
hours and all of this stuff right this
big like whatever deployment of of
something that that's to be said or
created or whatever it is and then you
get those little glimpses like during
like there's like no one home and it's
just this beautiful flow and it's like
wow miracle miracle dope dope dope and
then there's that little like glimpse of
like uh like something that wants to
like be like or whatever and then like
it's and then it's like get out of the
[__] we we know what happens when you
get like
get hey
yeah like the flow is so crystallized
and it's no longer Faith it's it's
conviction so that little feels too it
feels too much of a loss in energy
investment to focus and click play in
that old advertisement right right nice
nice good way to put it yeah right right
the the thing is like an ad yeah and you
click click into it and it's like an old
reel of patterns that is like yeah is
like yeah blah it's yeah it's something
that's been it's almost like I guess the
the loop the the code loop
itself has various ways of playing
itself out it it can be seen through at
more rapid in more rapid ways and
more clean more immediate transformative
ways or it can be kind of delayed where
there's still more clicking into the
loop until like suffering ramps up
enough and it's
like it's
okay okay yeah it's like it's like Liv
Liv Netflix it's like your life is so
fun that you can just choose which TV
show you want to get inside in I feel
like I become this little fairy and I'm
like okay let's get inside this TV show
and then it's like okay that wasn't that
fun let's get out what are my other
options oh let's get inside this TV show
right right right nice nice nice
resonate yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the whole the whole thing with
um yeah it's like another way to say it
is
like
um you know how like I guess what we
were what we've been talking about a lot
of this is like limitlessness playing
with
limits
basically yeah and then what and then
the the you could say one of the
contrasts or discernments in
the the movie options that are flowing
is that one of them has more limits and
one of them is more
Limitless yeah and so the whole thing of
the body's purification towards God's
will is just more and more Limitless in
its movie and you can sort of tell where
like
those like I I I it's like it becomes
more and more clear where the
advertisement comes up and it's just
like you can just see it's just a big
contra
action I
[Music]
contraction nice oh
that's that's so good that's so good
jeez that's so so
good it is so good yeah I mean that's
some next that's some next level
like life Mastery right there that is
next level [__] it's like it's like
limitlessness becomes the like
constant like like Discerning
flow and just oh I love you said
Discerning flow
nice because yeah it's infinite
surrender
Discerning yeah yeah nice right right
right because it's going to come it's
going to come up even though there is
like more and more deeper and deeper
infinite surrender there's still going
to be
this
popup the you can't what what is
all I I know it's ridiculous like
literally say a computer like you sure
you want to take this this your new
Choice sure this you're going to
are you sure and then you're like yes
and then it's like are you really sure
right right you get another chance
sometimes you like you can like open up
a message and the message will like be
pretty obvious that it's a quite a
contracted like and then you open it up
and you're like you're you know it's
like the the the call
button you know it's there like and you
get that moment it's
like it's like your second yeah but it's
strange because sometimes it's very
strange but I'll let me let me put this
into P into our field here so sometimes
when sometimes what limitlessness is
going through is calling into that
contraction I guess this is also the
Discerning flow and whatnot but it's
kind of just doing itself but just going
into that contraction because in a way
the contraction is
asking it's making a request to be more
Limitless right and so then the game
that's being played is well to what
degree does this contraction actually
want to be liberated basically
because if it's like if it's obvious
from the message that there's there's no
interest or if it's like a previous
track record of not really being
interested in being liberated then then
you're signing up for a replay of
programming
basically right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but if it if if it is more
open if it is more open it's shown uh
ripeness and all kinds of of of stuff
then then sometimes it can be intense
like you can get into that Catalyst
field and it'll be like limitlessness
interfacing with limits and it'll be
like it'll be snapping those limits you
know in the Battlefield in that war zone
yeah and then yes when you're done with
it after an hour maybe like two of the
eight that were being attached to or let
go of or whatever and the the one that
you you're speaking to is saying like
God I feel I feel more free in these two
ways thank you so much so then at that
point then you what just magical myum
money flows through the ether into
Nicole's
Pockets yes
basically it's like an infinite trust
fun to play my game just because I shows
to receive it I'm like okay I'm ready to
claim my Divine inheritance from
source so just being constituted as
ready to claim Divine inheritance from
source is enough for the one that felt
like they became more free from the
interaction
action just
spontaneously says can I send
you some money
for services yeah it's always a
service so it's so usually when if it's
if it's
a is it is it usually pretty cleanly
just comes up on their end like the the
the The Liberation that they feel the
expansion that they
feel it just naturally sort of flows for
them to be like how can I support you
basically well usually comes from I've
always had a business so right but I
don't have to work on my business it's
just like people just suddenly in spirit
Works through them or infinite
intelligence and they're like oh I'm
going to search her website and I'm
going to just subscribe today or I'm
going to send her an email and I want to
but it's because um I don't have to work
on it because I'm in a high frequency
planing in the field learning the
lessons that then I use to give back to
the people that are supporting that so
the only reason I can serve them is
because I have the direct experience of
what they want to
embody right exactly right okay so so
basically your beingness emanates in The
Ether and then you have enough funnels
on social media and and web for booking
and that kind of stuff that then
infinite intelligence moves their
beingness towards the limitlessness
towards the expansiveness and then it
also funnels Financial Resources in that
in that way basically it's a great yeah
it's a great way to humanize it yes yeah
yeah nice yeah it's it is kind of it's
fascinating cuz it's so Airy and it's
also very grounded at the same time
because it's literally a plant it's so
fascinating it's literally a plant
Network and the Airy part is kind of the
electrical part in a way cuz the
electrical part is so difficult to map
and understand but the the grounded part
is like it's obvious that there's
these bodies that are a clear cellular
evolution of of the earth and that they
are
like I I have no idea how the words go
out of this mouth and across the
internet and into these ears there's
no no idea at all about that that
thing but then the whole
like I don't know the whole ni thing I
don't know like pinching these nipples
like there's like a pretty clear like
sensation of being in a in a body
embodied and at the same time being
everywhere impossible to understand how
any of this is right right because I'm
like it's kind of ineffable to try to
put words into like the what it always
is so it's like the what is it's always
flowing in infinite abundance may it be
financially socially intellectually
artistically creativity like bodily it's
always flowing so can you list those
categories again because we the infinite
abundance in the categories
of financially creatively socially
spiritually slow slow down a little bit
so we can kind of feel into each one of
those categories infinite abundance in
each one of those categories okay I'm G
I'm going to shift the B the new TV show
these are the categories this are
rainbow guys get in the Nikki
program it's a rainbow yeah abundance in
finances okay yes which we've already
explored quite a bit so
next
okay social abundance social abundance
okay interesting so removing the
blockages around receiving
uh like view like viewership and family
in that way
that like for online but also social
abundance in the form of like meeting
like higher net worth
people yeah friendship um soulmate
friends support in every single
way and it doesn't feel like support
it's like equal because once the
vibration is raised into the frequency
of press it you just abide in a
different reality with avatars or people
soulmates that are already abiding in
the frequency of abundance so you always
have an exact reflection of what you
believe you can
experience right okay
so I like that so the social unblocking
is what you would call like equals on
the sole level of socialization yeah so
like always like basically like best
best friends is another way to to say it
like like ones where the whole spectrum
is online on both parties and it's
very effortless and um Flow full easy
easy okay so that's social
abundance
yes next
intellectual
abundance okay so what is I think I have
that one I think I have that one quite a
bit Yeah I came from your field I never
say that I'm like why am I saying this
is this
your no that one's insane here I don't
think I I don't know if I've ever not
had intellectual abundance honestly I
think my entire life I've had
intellectual abundance it's been insane
F yeah I'm like always I don't know if
I've ever had a contraction in
intellectual abundance like my my
entire beingness is constantly being
um pummeled pummeled by the most
delicious and
nutritious yeah
intellectualness that feeds perfectly
into what is created it's just it's a
it's a miracle that one F yes okay cool
okay uh what does it look like if there
is like lack in intellectual abundance
what is that like I love your question
you're like what does that mean that
means that the flow of infinite
creativity that every being has
potential to tap into is blocked by the
clouds of
fear okay interesting so you're you're
because I think I heard you say create
cretive was another thing but you're
kind of bringing some of that into the
intellectual piece so meaning
um the GI basically the the unique gifts
that the Universe wants to bring through
the body are are being Limited in some
way and some of that is like an INT
intellectual
block yeah what what is an intellectual
Block in that in that way kind of like
basically a belief of notw worthiness is
a big one probably I mean that's too
broad so I want to make it more specific
I mean that's like the whole Collective
unworthiness everybody has a unique
genius yet it is blocked
by saying yes to a version of
reality that that soul is choosing out
of fear and not remember remance of
their intellectual capacity maybe you
were blessed by the remembrance of your
intellect at a young age so you have
been able to potentiate
it so now it's just like oh that's easy
that's but some people have that
block out of not have given them the
they haven't given themselves the chance
to activate it right right okay so okay
so one of the ways maybe that that's can
that that can come up relatably as like
there can be sometimes the felt like
Divine spark of inspiration that comes
and then it is kind of like shut down by
some sort of of
response BEC out of fear Bas like
basically fear of riding the surf which
and then the the riding the surf usually
leads to the unknown which
includes like uh the possibility of more
door opening or the possibility of that
creativity Landing in the hearts of
those that are receiving it and then
that that can feedback loop onto itself
in a positive way as long as the surface
is taken and not feared the creative
spark I feel really like that that one
that one's such a big one cuz by taking
the creative spot
spark
yeah like that's the whole point is to
take the creative
spark right right that's the next level
of okay fear doesn't exist now
what because let's say let's say the
basic needs are met like we've been
chatting about in in envisioning for the
new world and how we're moving more and
more in that direction with these
communities every single day once that's
met basically abundance infinite basic
needs then the then the only thing left
is to always be riding the wave of the
creative
spark yes right there's a subtlety there
though because before I took on my quest
of remembrance I always had my basic
needs met
too yet it was given too easy so I was
like did I created this so so back to an
example of the Avatar of the millionaire
client they have the basic needs met and
more but they can be intellectually and
creatively blocked because they're not
riding the wave of abundance just right
empty money right right right that's a
good point so meaning even with uh basic
needs being met there's still some sort
of
a like div divination or initi ation
school with learning how to ride the
creative spark that one is yeah yeah
nice okay so all right so that's
intellectual what was after intellectual
abundance so that's also creative would
you say those two can kind of be the
same yeah
because I believe that the highest
Genius of someone is the intellect that
comes from source which is your
creativity not the ego intellect that
comes from books yes yes yes
exactly that's literally what Everything
is Everything
is the Divine
creativity of infinity and it's
unbelievable like that's that's the
coolest it kind of pisses me off
sometimes when there's like um too too
much um
uh art
artificially uh ground creating an
artificial ground in emptiness or
voidness or or being null or any of
those things because it kind of it
basically says
that the creativity of that is not as
important or it's not as or
it's
or like basically the embodied
experience isn't some something about it
it's like trying to in a way it it can
sometimes be an escape it's a beautiful
place to get to to know what one is at
that level but it has to be integrated
back into the into the Divine creativity
that of what this
is yeah sometimes there's an avoidance
of even that like even there's an
avoidance of it being creative like
in
yeah I mean we're creating even if we
believe we're not creating we're always
creating something so may as well just
right like nice I love intentional with
the creation I love that even
interesting so it's it's always Infinite
Creation even if you
are relaxed in the deepest of void
imaginable or in the worst case scenario
even if you're in poverty Consciousness
or beggar separate person Consciousness
from your Infinity you're creating that
experience because you want to have that
movie yes yes yes every single
um nerve ending is Infinity's desire to
be completely out out of control Wild
and
Free in all of these ways which is so so
crazy the [__] yes the [__] War
one and poverty one so so so
insane but um okay so let's let's
continue so what's after intellect and
creativ
abundance bodily that you already kind
of mentioned how to integrate the
creative flow that's coming from Source
into the root into the ground so instead
of just oh down download speech it's
download Heart Center solar plexus root
integration yum okay now from a space of
grounded embodiment this flows through
me in an aligned way because I'm not
trying
to accomplish or prove to my ego that I
am someone or I am doing something it's
just oh now that there's no attachment
to outcome because there's no fear
creativity flows the highest
expression okay so body abundance is
tied to creativity in the sense of being
out like the small self being out of the
way of the creativity so it's not about
itself but it's about the whole yes okay
okay cool so that's where the bodily
abundance
interesting and I mean it's also tied to
self-care nice yeah that that's good too
yeah I'm noticing that that's
actually in some ways being like
very Matrix
repressed
um in all kinds of ways um
but bodily abundance in the form of
taking really good care of the body
is it's it's so so intimately connected
to create the
creative abundance so much so much those
two things go hand in hand Body Care
Plus the channel is the same thing it's
crazy yeah it's the vehicle like proper
sleep
like routine stretches movement oh my
God yes oh my
gosh start moving yeah oh my
gosh light it's just it's not possible
to be embodied without deep liberation
of the body vehicle itself it just it
needs to constantly
be liberated of all of its cellular and
muscular and nerve contractions at
deeper and deeper levels just like a
couple days ago I I was again no no
one's doing it more and more it's just
the universe is laying on the carpet and
it's just doing its weird monkey body
stretches right just doing its weird
monkey body stretches and all of a
sudden it gets into this super weird
position where you know one of the arms
is up like this and then the this you
know I'm bringing my knee up here this
thing this this other the other leg was
down like and it was doing this crazy
full body you know stretch from from up
here all the way down down down down leg
and it was opening up the quad and the
Seas and all of these parts you know the
really deep uh not
undernourished the things that monkeys
can get
to because they're natural and
spontaneous and not contracted like
humans where we're in our minds and
avoiding our bodies and stuff yeah but
when you get into that SOA or whatever
that contracted or like you know the
back is another place and all this kind
of stuff when you get into that through
actually nourishing your body it's crazy
how it's like gunpowder how the creative
like it just starts raining
creativity yeah
yeah that was so important and also
because the programs the conditionings
are stored in the nerves and the
cells so any subtlety or any like the
deepest of the imprint like I love
looking at people's kic
imprints sometimes it has to like be
pushed out like to the root and like how
much self-love and self-care can you
give your vehicle to pushed out all
that's no longer
serving have you seen the ad you've seen
like adhesions that like like muscular
tensions and and whatnot have you have
you seen those surf on the skin of the
body as they
leave oh no how is it so it's kind of
like you know how the with the like with
the contractions of of like the mind or
like this upper area it's like its own
kind of catharsis basically is kind of
like what happens it's very like
cathartic pretty much like like way like
well I'm talking about kind of like when
someone's going through a purge or
they're going through some sort of like
wailing or grieving or whatever like
full like those kinds of releases those
are more common people see in
transformative work but in terms of like
bodily like muscular adhesion releases
and
stuff I'm talking about
like like you're like you're in there
for hours every single day in whatever
part of the body and you're really kind
of liberating that area and all of a
sudden you start seeing the surfacing at
the level of the skin yes the pathology
that was baked in there it's fascinating
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
experienced that too it's it's
fascinating it's like oh okay the
conditioning was coming out and then
it's like rasist or like I'm like oh
yeah so so visceral that that [__] was
in there like get out of here yes yes
yes I mean that
not mosquito so everybody just one
minute yeah yeah
cool I'll keep I'll keep the the live
chat uh excited because I love you guys
in the live chat it's been so fun there
it was this way okay go
go you guys have been so fun to watch
what you've been talking about and how
the family is coming together
and across this Channel and across
Nikki's
Channel and what you guys are all
talking about and how you're bonding
together and how
you're like the conversation you're
having so cool
here how you're reflecting on what we're
talking about the live chats reflecting
on what we're talking about it's like
people that have come from watching this
Channel and watching your channel coming
together and being like I don't know
what one of these comments was so
beautiful it was something like uh I
love the play here so few places for
authenticity these days a so beautiful
thank you that's so cool I love this
family man this is this is our this is
our fam you
know that's so cool these are the types
of conversations
that that uh and these are the types of
conversations and family and community
that we're excited about you know do do
these things in person isn't that the
whole doubt exactly yeah right
experience yeah AB absolutely yeah
eventually having you know starting off
with just smaller homesteads like 20 50
100 people in the first kind of
Homestead developments across different
continents though like different
continents literally so the network of
light cities is already but certain ones
only have like a couple like a dozen
people at them and
stuff but eventually get to the point
where it becomes so easy to Homestead
like the interface is like Star Trek
like it's so [__] easy to use it and
it's like a miracle like how beautiful
it is and how modular it is like you can
easily design your home that you want a
homestead and have it be plugged into
all of the basic needs Assets in that
community that are already that are yeah
and then within some period like five
seven years or so be completely
financially free of the roof over your
head also okay nice and then as we get
some of our free energy Technologies
Roar
roaring we can even move
between light
cities super quickly super efficiently
super um what did you say re
re
remunerated or replenish replenishing
renourished exactly everything is
infinite in that sense of replenished
and renourished there with no scarcity
or fear and then
we're then we're like by the way at
these light cities we're envisioning
that all these light cities whether they
have you know anywhere from a thousand
to millions of people eventually will
have centerpieces maybe even multiple
centerpieces like vortexes basically so
yeah yeah yeah so have you ever heard of
like machra mandere over in
oraville what is it
well since
uh since we have our our handy
dandy I love that concept of free energy
I mean that's kind of like what I'm
talking about same thing yeah you are
talking about that we are talking about
that exact same thing yes yeah this is
a well I'm showing the the on on the
video right now what matrand Deere is
it's uh it's this
gorgeous um Vortex like centerpiece in
the in the unity Consciousness community
in Oroville in India over on
the on the eastern
coast near uh north of
pondicherry and it's just got this
unbelievable um like internal meditation
chamber where it's like it's reflecting
the it's reflecting the sun's it's
following and reflecting refracting the
Sun's light cool into the meditator
chamber and it's lighting up this
transparent huge transparent
Crystal that the meditators are seeing
as a reflection of unity consciousness
of the clear open
space n it's unbelievable and so
basically if we get if we get these
types of of uh let me see if I can do M
mere interior I know it's it's harder to
find it because you're not allowed
to bring your devices oh yeah cool there
it
is uh so this is what the the inside
looks like this picture specifically is
insane so yeah it's
um yeah it's like it's like a perfect um
like centerpiece like if we get
centerpieces like these when we get
centerpieces like these across these
light cities it'll be game over because
within the light cities these vortexes
are going to be like the the core of the
communities and then around them is
going to be these
incredible like Parks unbeliev like the
coolest water park n natural reserves
imaginable it's going to be like the
coolest
Hangouts [__] yes yeah yeah I mean
sounds like bringing back Atlantis just
like Earthly now it's like okay now
it's on the
top nice
yes
exactly so okay so what else was in the
list what did we just we did body we did
body
abundance yeah what was after
that
um I mean this
one's I don't know if I would say
spiritual abundance yet it's tied to
creativity yet everything's spiritual so
it's more like connection to your heart
consistent connection to
Heart how is it how is that different
from intellectual
it's not about creating it's about
abiding in a consistent state of Peace
doesn't matter what shows
up what if I want to be a raging [__]
for the new earth oh that
too that's the that's the thing that's
what shows up it's like the rage it's
appearing on the piece yet you know that
it's just you don't get hooked with the
appearance you're just like oh cool
playing rage yeah yeah yeah like still
Stillness raging Stillness
raging oh okay cool it's so it's like
the X-Men mansion mission that I have so
it's kind of like you have all these
suits and you just know you're like this
X-Men Avatar and you're like okay which
suit I want to wear today but you know
you don't have to keep the suit you can
just take it
off yet it's an authentic suit it's not
like a mask it's just like oh today I
want to authentically be right whatever
nice nice nice Yeah Yeah well yeah this
is the shape shifter to yeah this is it
so the what do you call the so anyone
that's uh able to access any of the
superpowers of the X-Men basically you
you call that just like an X-Men
basically X-Men abundance X-Men
abundance it's part of the program you
get X-Men abundance yeah yeah yeah yeah
totally
I feel like I just uh started liberating
the spiritual straight jacket that was
put on around um not being able to uh
rage like like emanating God's Wrath for
as a warrior for New Earth basically for
the injustices of the
contractivity like so like that's its
own X-Men suit basically yes yeah and
then there's another there's another
X-Men suit which is like when I when
there's
like whatever like Fielding the like
there's like the the we have a we have a
dog here and like the dog like obviously
there's no concept of new Earth Warrior
when there's the presence of the
unconditional love of the dog and and
whatnot and so there's obviously some
sort of weird like unified melt
basically that is
yeah yes yes that's sweet yet I love
that to touch the subject of the rage
because sometimes chaos has to
appear to shift things up so there there
can be even more harmonious peace nice
yes
yes cool oh yeah oh yeah that's that's
crucial I've I've actuallya the chaos or
the disharmony or the Rage or whatever
on the Injustice or the contraction or
whatever that's sometimes the the way to
for the contraction to to W wobble and
loosen um for there to actually be
Harmony or
expansion so by repressing the Catalyst
that's trying to flow out to liberate
that contraction yeah yeah it's it's
actually doing the opposite effect and
that's why that's why the spiritual [__]
is one of the
most deceptive Straight
Jackets it's some it's in some ways it's
even more deceptive than the than the
separation straight
jacket yeah exactly because it hides
behind fake peace it's like are you
really peaceful like is it really
peaceful or is it suppression of Rage or
anger or are you truly expressing what
you want to say like I
love yes yes yes yes
yes
yeah feels
good the mouthpiece not being liberated
is even more of a trap and contraction
than separation is in many
ways it yeah go ahead go ahead it's like
a baby pacifier like a yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah baby
fire fake be fake be yeah yeah
yeah
like like so much of the of the of the
creative
potential and the Divine spark of the
creative abundance it's dependent on
that pacifier being
obliterated I love use that word I can
see like a fire like bursting in the
fifier
like yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah the pacifier is good it's also
kind of like like a muzzle another one a
muzzle on on yeah it's it's intense it's
just a muzzle in that
way it's it's I okay so much there if
you can't if you can't um like free the
nipple like as you know the male body if
you can't free the nipple if you if you
can't if you can't you know make the
joke about you know about like
ah you know if you can't make these
kinds of jokes
exactly are you free are you really free
or is there something about the
self-image that is still wanting to be
held on
to yeah something about
it right and you can you can say that
you can say that oh well like well
perhaps by not doing such wild
things than the catalysts that are that
are that are said are more well-received
there's lots of ways to to put it or
formulate
it
right but for example here here it
doesn't that would feel so untrue or
inauthentic so it just yeah it just
wildly does its its thing and
then yeah you know what's crazy is the
the getting
responses
from um people that have been watching
for a long time it's like me watching
this body you know through those eyes
it's like what and then like that's been
watching for a long time now and then
it's like being like dude crazy like
fascinating [__] that's been recently
happening like basically their responses
are like
it's almost like clear that there was
some game being like a repressed game
being played which was what we were
calling a spiritual program or whatever
Co so you mean like the audience was
even opening up more as a reflection
of the liberation of the
animal right right yeah yeah so the the
the free flowing of this mouthpiece is
generating those expansive catalyst for
those that are receiving the content
because now it's seen
that what am I
repressing and why and why when where
when was when where was the program
even that was that was running it does
seem like some sort of like basically in
a way a contractive agenda to
suppress some some of the basically the
new Earth in in a nutshell um which is
beautiful I mean it's the infinity War
it's it's got to be this way but holy
it's Infinity War but
holy but holy [__]
is is that there's so many facets to the
straight jacket like all kinds
of little you know ties right it's a
literal like constrain program it's like
take off the jacket it's like wait what
was I wearing a jacket yeah it's like
take it off and then like show up
however you want to show up in the
moment even if it's free to nip yeah
yeah or if it's Rage or anger it's God
expressing us
anger yeah and
like if it comes back to the peace I
mean that's the thing like when to know
it's not like conditioning because it
just shows up us that and then it's like
relaxes
exactly yeah the underlying current of
it all is that like it's almost like
effortless how much you never leave it
it's like you you you get so beautifully
like embodied in it and then at the same
time it's made of it and you never leave
it and it's just fascinating
cuz yeah it's just like but like getting
drunk
on not playing or and whatnot is is like
I think that's another huge spiritual
straight jacket is Guy basically being
drunk on not playing and um not playing
fully to what wants to happen in that
moment
yeah even if it means a sacrifice of
self-image or right Collective judgment
or exactly yeah yep those are those are
the big ones those are the those are the
big ones and then also the limit the
self we're talking so much about
abundance and limitlessness the liit the
self that self-imposed limit of the gift
not flowing we were talking pacifier
muzzle whatever there's all ways the
cellular memories of fear of being
authentic or whatever there's all kinds
of ways to say it but right those limits
are to be shattered
yeah because we want to see you coming
Fully Alive into the play
basically yeah right it's
like love when you look at the audience
yeah I'm like hi
hi it's like instead of watching TV
you're living the movie back to it's
like full circle it's like you want to
truly live the movie as a limitless
character that's even the character I
mean
energy show up as you
are and maybe that's not you but then
how would you know it's not you until
you play it and get reflected that
that's not you
so showing up and then there's
discernment with that
too
yeah
yes who can really
know yeah yeah it's like I'm like trying
to put into words Infinity we can
try like a monkey I'm like I can
try yeah yeah yeah
so discernment so what what could we say
about it like how can we identify if
it's a reflection from God's Source
appearing as Rage or it's just
conditioning and
projection or rage can be anything how
do we discern
between is it conditioning or
authenticity
well one's a bit more like I guess
selfish programs and the other is more
like selfless flow for the
whole
how
sweet
yeah
this whole this whole episode ended up
being on this topic in different
ways like Prosperity or limitlessness
but in all these different ways which is
super
cool even though we started on the like
financial and what not we got into all
these other ways or is there another one
that you want to
list Legacy calling work but it
encompasses yeah yeah all the others
it's like when all the others are in
check you're instantly your calling
right yep
nice without trying
exactly nice yeah like all those all the
engines are yeah fully
online and it's like yeah continuous
calling super good and um you when we
were saying that like the title of it
had like you know po poverty uh to
Prosperity um that the PO fascinating
that poverty itself is not just
Financial poverty but it's B body
poverty and intellectual poverty and
creative poverty and calling poverty and
spiritual poverty it's just a limit in
that sense it's limit limit limit limit
limit limit limit it's all limit limit
limit limit and then it's Limitless
Prosperity is
Limitless so the poverty is just limit
limit limit limit limit in all these
different dimensions that we talked
about and then it's obliterating all of
those
contractions which are which is our
school you know our school has been that
so never forget that the school has been
just
incredible the school itself you mean
life yeah like all of those contractions
were so deeply serving like every single
time that one of them goes it's like
it's its own you know crucifixion death
rebirth type thing and it's it's so
powerful because each one of them
it it's like it's you kind of like you
you
know so you know your own like your own
Dojo you know you're just like yeah like
like the Matrix when they have the
program
of yeah exactly exactly yeah yeah yeah
you g your own Sensei Stripes like good
job yes yes exactly yeah yeah like
exactly what was encoded as the
contraction has
been uh deciphered you know expanded
and it's like like you like see
the like the beauty in how the
the how
the the the two are the same intertwined
and like that's the magic that's really
the
magic like the contraction and expansion
are the same intertwined in the same and
then so yeah getting into it
really it's like yeah it's like the
ma the contractive magic that's and then
getting into it and then the gemstone of
the expansion it's like that whatever
that is like that's the
coolest have you ever heard of not
Theory all these
different there's like not not not not
like K like k n o t like Nots oh okay
it's like infinite ways
to to make twists basically basically
yes like every day it's like how do you
would you like to contract
today
yeah it when I you did that it was like
a rose to me I saw like the rose just
flowing in different configurations of
Explorations
nice
so it's like the universe is making love
to itself in every second when you get
out of the way and then you can always
feel blissed because you're always in
the making love experience instead of
Contracting yourself like when can I
finally come or when can I finally like
you know it's like instead of from the
contraction trying to like find the
release just get in the wave and always
be in the making love experience exactly
perfectly sad I love that yeah visceral
yet I'm like how else can way better way
better though to be on the like that's
one of my favorite Parts about like uh
like sport is that it you have you're
like forced to be in the flow on the
wave or whatever you're forced or music
or whatnot you're like forced to be on
it and in it like so
like ra like rather than like oh like
you're not awaiting the end of the game
or the end of the musical piece or the
liberation of from the contraction or
whatever you're you're like the flow
itself is the sex the flow itself yeah
so you're always fulfilled like you're
always on the peak of the wave or the
peak of the orgasm without having to
receive the outcome yeah like you're
always like having fun yeah nice yes
yes and that's like how we started the
episode was that like
what what are we what's
happening yeah what the [__]
like yeah exactly being able to tap into
that at well that's like
liberating right and it's crazy that
like like learning how to like like lay
down and be by yourself or be sitting
under a tree on a walk or whatever and
just like like that's the perfect
Indescribable flow itself like like that
is right
that's that's the universe's [__] shot
right there like it's
always it's
crazy what the we were we were talking
about this before we started that we we
are the [__] and the eggs already like
we're always [__] like the words
themselves like the this is [__] like
words spoken and received or from there
spoken and received is sex in a way
everything yeah yeah it's like a cosmic
orgy yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah people it's like what I'm like
that's what it is so choose your
preferred movie cu yeah you're always
making love to
something
yeah and how this ties to the whole
poverty thing like or lack Consciousness
you cannot sit and do nothing if you're
worried about
lack so that's like the basis of right
being the infinite jiggle like the
abundance Consciousness like that's
needed for it yes yes exactly nice right
that's great that's a great tie into
like the meat of what we talked about
because one of the best ways to learn if
you actually have a limitless or
abundance beingness is can you
sit and do nothing and like feel the
cosmic
sex without moving just sitting there
alone without any outside no
stimulation no movement pure
aloneness and if you get really good
also at meditation like the calming of
the mind and its thoughts even though
all thoughts are made of it but
just holy [__] can yeah can what is so
deeply desired and sought just be full
fully sad into and then from
there H like that's yeah that's what
that's home that's abundance that's
that's limitlessness and then from there
like new Earth and everything that it
like the gifts all everything is
just I love how we I love how we talked
about the like the liberating you you
can see it more clearly though those
limits and the contractions from there
you can see it more clearly from when
it's coming from there you can catch
more clearly where
H
yeah you see if you're if you're really
fast can be you just do the whole
thing yeah yeah code code code no thank
you yes yes please [__] yes
no expansion nice nice yes yes that was
such a good part too
[__]
popup no thank you B it's kind of like
it it's kind of like it it pop it pops
up and it has its own little like like
when discernment I guess gets really
sharp there's like its own little like I
guess AI rating on it it's like you know
like
24% chance for expanding to limits and
it's like I don't
know pre previous session you know
didn't really go into the limits with
earnestness or whatever like you know
like that's fascinating like it's like
that kind
of like instant yeah yeah creator of
intuitive
knowing yeah yeah
yes yes that gets perfected out of the
past wrong clicks
exactly I already click in there no yeah
yeah
yeah oh my
gosh what a
crazy um
beautiful second episode this has been
it's been so
cool wow yeah
yeah it's crazy wow so that was like a
year and two was it two years it was
probably two yeah it was two years from
the car one yeah two years yeah yeah
that's it's it's fascinating seeing what
transformed and then how it comes
together and what it kind of like the
words that it uses and how it chats
about
itself the infinite AI inside this
monkey yeah yeah God we chatted about
ourselves much in a different like in a
fascinatingly like
different way almost like we had both
like found what found what we were and
how we work at a deeper level and we
could come together and discuss
that yeah
yeah I mean
wow yeah wow like wow and it's like such
beautiful confirmation whatnot I'm
like if today I'm feeling like this has
been epic I'm like what else can happen
What
right it's already so good so good holy
[__] we we just entered a timeless
portal for sure
yeah yeah that
was it was like yeah what the [__] what
the infinite what the [__] [__]
yeah my
heart
yeah
[Music]
damn
wow
you been here for like five hours yeah I
know I'm looking at the episode timing
it's like okay it's been: 142 okay okay
yeah go ahead no yeah but before so I'm
just like oh yeah because we did talk
for like whatever two hours beforehand
that's true yeah we've been in a long
portal today it's been beautiful
yeah here like bista
yay God in the first two hours had their
own texture to it
also
crazy yeah
yeah this is what this is what we were
talking about regarding that that like
social that social soul level connecting
full spectrum and finding that
family so sweet for
sure yeah you a year ago in Paris it was
like we were like okay yeah we'll meet
up for a couple hours and then it was
like dude it's just like it's like
impossible to stop hanging
out like they a row okay can okay
tomorrow yeah okay tomorrow see you okay
sounds good like it's like you just had
to there's just too much code that had
to be exchanged I mean kind of like kind
of like this one there was just a lot of
code again
in the yeah in what we talked about
before what we talked about during the
show like so
much cool
settings next meeting should be Tokyo or
something right that's
interesting have you been no I don't
know where that came up yeah that's
interesting I haven't been yet but I've
heard such good things about Japan you
yeah
so who knows right in that uh whatever
that that like main whatever that crazy
main intersection or like outside Mount
like Fuji or whatever
like yeah
yeah holy [__] and also just
possibly you know we took we took two
years and it was nice because holy [__]
there was a lot of update but uh but we
can do this we can explore doing this
more often too and just see what kind of
codes because it's interesting also
seeing that a good amount of both of our
our our Channel homies like coming
together for for the convo and whatnot
so so yeah let's see
uh let's see what happens when we do
these
osmosis cool
yeah Blissful
dates Blissful
dates with
infinity the the infinite date the
infinite date it never ends never
ends you're just in an infinite date
with yourself exactly yes
nice infinite date yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah every every engagement with
yourself is its own date it's its own
date its own date you
know like M mom's a certain kind of date
like Nikki's a certain kind of
date your person that's coming in for
the transformative Works another kind of
date like each one of them is like its
own more me in them vice versa yeah
exactly every single time it's that it's
like yes yeah yeah yeah a new flavor of
God in another it's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah flavors of flavors of God yeah that
maybe that's our next episode title the
flavors of God yeah I love it that's
pretty
cool
right
right okay well we we wish literally
everyone that's watching this and that
will have watched this we wish you um
incredible abundance and um shattering
every single imaginable limit and um
total Prosperity
yeah [__] yes infinite
flavors yeah yeah infinite flavors of
shattering limits and to Prosperity I
love
that oh my gosh okay so um we have
Nikki's uh let's let's actually let's
let's bring it up so we have
her her YouTube channel is linked in the
bio below so she's posting content on
there quite often across a a variety of
of awesome transformative
topics so go and check those
out and subscribe over there
and you can also follow her on Instagram
and the link that link is below and if
you want to uh have a a a session
there's a link there's a link here for
signing up for or emailing the Nikki's
email is also in the description you can
reach
out and there's you do a you do a 15
minute offering and a 60 Minute offering
right I saw uh yeah um I do remote as
well I can work on people's Fields
without a session so if they're
interested in those types of healing
they can email
me um and I do portals one month long
containers with three Souls at a time
time and I have one in December 12th I
have two people in and there's one more
spot if somebody's interested they can
also email me 1222
portal interesting what are what are
your offerings you said you do you do
sessions that are like shorter long
sessions than you do ones that are
completely
remote and then
so I have one Synergy call so if
somebody wants to connect for 15 20
minutes that's free although I'm fully
booked till March or April of those
Synergy calls I do remote healings so
they can send me an email and we don't
have to meet on Zoom it's just I can tap
into people's fields from a distance and
provide healing and opening of their
energy centers and that comes with one
session too and I have month-long
containers that I do sometimes like
every three months or so and I have one
opening on December
12th
okay and the three-month containers are
a small
group oh no every three months I have a
one month container oh every three
months is a one month container and how
many people are in that three it's
really intimate okay
yes interesting and then how many times
do you meet with them during that month
month Wednesday and Friday and we have a
telegram portal open okay every day
voice notes and text three times a week
for an
hour an hour hour and a half sometimes
too like whatever needs to happen yeah
just yeah
yeah it's like a boost like let's move
through the next phase of life like in a
month
like like boost through yeah yeah you're
nice it's like those Mar you know those
Mario Kart um oh yeah when you have you
could go that's what it is yeah nice
that's that's a good analogy very very
relatable one
yeah yeah yeah and sometimes you got to
catch the Boost strip to ramp up to
collect the box that has a power up in
it you know and stuff yeah yeah yeah and
then when they leave the container then
they keep the box so they can keep
moving fast yeah yeah yeah because they
whatever that that power up that they
got was they're now able to deploy that
in their field in their wisdom and and
use it
for their gifts and like that's
beautiful nice it is really a boost I
like that it's a boost it's almost like
because the code is already there so
sometimes it's like a the freeing of a
limit but it ends up being a boost is
what it ends up yeah
yeah
gosh this Mario analogy is so good like
totally nice okay so that's um that's
the offerings those are all in the
description and let's see um subscribe
to the channel if you haven't yet like
the video share it with those that you
feel like would have a fun time giggling
with us and talking about all facets of
abundance
yeah
oh um comment below with uh with what
was most resonant for you we'd love to
hear from
you and oh yeah you can check out the
links in the description for home da you
can get involved uh in decentralizing
basic needs infrastructures and and uh
homesteading and getting into these new
Earth
communities yeah and um
yeah the new Atlant yes
yes
um and there's yeah there's some more uh
links that are on uh the on on my
website in the description also which
has all kinds of stuff like there's
coaching stuff there there's other
projects there there's also a solar Punk
Gallery which I [__] love it's like
all the it's like a new Earth um collage
of
uh uh I love that solar Punk yeah I'm G
I'll I'll bring it up so so we'll have
it in
the in video so here under solar
Punk is
this this
catalog of just
stunning new Earth
architectures and
blueprints of Perfect Harmony of
indigenous wisdom with oh modern
technology [__] yes exact perfect
harmony with infinite
technology that's it's like this well
now it's dark it's like
the it's like nature with this really
Hightech infrastructure isn't it ex
exactly yeah that's exactly it yes yeah
oh it's funny because most of us most of
us have had the vision that that's what
the new Earth is like so it's it's even
coming in a decentralized way that so
many people have been talking about
these light cities where it's a perfect
merging of indigenous nature wisdom with
utopic modern Technologies infinite
Technologies infinite abundance like
it's just like it's perfect it's a
perfect mix it's just that all those
contractions are to be expanded in order
for that to to to actually
flow because while there's all
that this this is not doesn't let the
float yeah yeah that doesn't go through
the Mario Kart slide yeah I was just
about to say that too yeah
exactly yeah this this is the banana
peels yeah which then make you spin off
of the
track yeah and then you have to wait so
the movie traps Matrix booby traps yes
yes yes yes including all kinds of
selfing endless endless selfing and
limits yeah endless
selfing endless self
absorption andless
validation right right and
more of this more of
this more of that
yes that booah
booah sweet sweet so I'll uh I'll end
the stream now thanks everyone for
tuning in uh stay for a bit we'll we'll
we'll we'll uh we'll keep you know
infinite date yeah oh my gosh yeah okay
much love
everyone
[Music]
bye